مرحب مرحب يا هلال اهلا اهلا كيف الحال قد
غبت واليك اشتقنا وانتهب عنك
مرحبا مفاجات كثيره تحميلها مسلسلات رمضان
المرتقبه وبقوه اجمل هذه المفاجات عن
اصوات الفنانين والفنانات على تترات هذه
المسلسلات حيث كشفت مصادر ان ابرز
المتواجدين ان النجوم الغناء في مسلسلات
رمضان لهذا العام ياسين التهامي في مسلسل
ستهم لروجينا محمد الحلو وحنان ماضي في
مسلسل ضرب نار الياسمين عبد العزيز واحمد
العوضي محمد منير في مسلسل عمله نادره
كريم احمد سعد لمسلسل جعفر العمده اللي
يخوض بطولته محمد رمضان ومدحت صالح في
مسلسل حضره العمده لروبي وغيرهم كثير
مفاجات اسعدت الجمهور جدا خاصه مع عوده
مغنيه تتراث الشهيرين جدا من اهم تترات
زمان
ما بين التلفزيون والمنصات اصبح النجوم في
حيره من امرهم فالمسلسلات التلفزيونيه
تختلف عن تلك التي تعرض على المنصات من
عده نواحي في مقدمتها حريه الطرح محدوديه
الحلقات والكرمه الانتاجي فايهما يفضلون
مسلسلات التلفزيون هم التي تعرض على
المنصه اقول الكلمه دائما يعني اقولها في
الوقت الحالي المنصه لا تقل اهميه عن
التلفزيون
وست حلقات او عشر حلقات لا تقل اهميه عن
30 حلقه كممثله ايش الافضل لك او تحبيه
اكثر وليش انا ممثله افضل كل شيء ما هذه
اول تجربه وبشوف اذا بعد يعني استحسنته
ممكن نعملها اذا هذا انا متعود على
الثلاثين يعني ايه
فممكن نزيدها يمكن نقصصها تقصص ولا نخليها
30 انا شخصيا افضل المسلسلات القصيره اني
احس انه يكون فيها فرصه لاتقان اكثر
والابداع اكثر يعني عندك وقت تزين عندك
وقت تحلي الفرق ما بين العمل للتلفزيون
مسلسل العرفه ينعرض لرمضان مثلا والعمل
لمسلسل للمنصات ايش الاحلى وليش والله كل
حلو
كله حلو يعني في قصه ملمومه بس تعطون
يعطونا الزبده ليش نطولها الثلاثين حلوه
في قصص تتحمل
[موسيقى]
بعد اعلان الاعتزال عام 2018 يعود الفنان
يوسف الجراح في الجزء الجديد من مسلسل طاش
ما طاش مع ناصر القصبي وعبد الله السدحان
حيث كان هذا العمل هو سبب شهرته في الماضي
وتحديدا شخصيه اسعد عمر قلي طبعا اللي
كلنا نعرفها الجراح لم يعلن الابتعاد بل
الاستمرار من نافذه اخرى غير التمثيل الى
العاب طاش ليعيدوا مره اخرى
اكون اقرب اكثر الى الله
للناس اني ابغى انزل له ما ابغى استديو مش
عارف ايه
وابغاكم كذا جنبهم
نايل مايك ونطلع في الشارع ومش عارف مين
حسيت بحنان
حنان
عربه الفنانه منال سلامه مع سعادتها
البالغه بعد النجاح اللي حققته بشخصيتها
فايزه اللي جسدها ضمن الاحداث مسلسل
الاصلي اللي يتناول عده قضايا اجتماعيه
واقعيه حول الارث وصراع الاشقاء وكذلك
المنافسه ما بين كبار تجار قطع غيار
السيارات واللي يشارك في بطوله مجموعه
كبيره من الفنانين ما بينهم ايناس كامل
ولا شريف اسلام جمال وغيرهم كاميرا كواليس
كان لها هذا الحوار مع منال سلام مش عايزه
حرق المسلسل لانه المسلسل معروض دلوقتي
ومعروض على
منصات
هو عيله
بيدور من خلالها حكايات ومشاكل اساسها
الورث
فكل لان احنا مجموعه اخوات
واختنا الكبيره انا الكبيره الاخت الاصغر
مني بتدير الشغل نظر انها متربيه في
شغلانه مع الاب من هنا بيحصل الخلاف
[موسيقى]